This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hello everybody. I'm Jemma Spake and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show.
这是一个I-Heart播客。保证真人。大家好，我是杰玛·斯派克（Jemma Spake），欢迎回到《你的二十岁心理学》，在这里我们探讨二十岁时面临的最大改变、重要时刻与人生过渡，以及它们对我们心理的意义。大家好，欢迎回到本节目。
Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here. You specifically, of course, back for another episode as we break down. the psychology of our 20s. Quick reminder, before we start, this episode you are currently listening to is also on Netflix worldwide, as are actually all of our other episodes in video form. So if you are someone who prefers to watch your podcasts or to have me kind of talking your way in the background whilst you're cleaning at the gym, working from home,
欢迎回到本播客。很高兴你能来到这里。当然，特别欢迎你——作为老听众再次收听新的一期节目，和我们一起剖析二十岁的心理。温馨提示，在开始之前，你目前正在收听的这期节目也已经在全球Netflix上线，我们的所有其他节目实际上也都有视频版本。所以，如果你是一个喜欢看播客，或者喜欢在打扫卫生、去健身房、在家办公时听我在耳边唠叨的人，
whatever it is, go and check out the link in the description and you can watch a full Netflix episode. Let's get into it. We're going to begin this episode with a, Hear Me Out. Hear me out. The best part of being in your 20s is realizing you are not the person that you once were. The worst part is realizing once more that you can never be those people again, no matter how hard you try or how much you want to go back. It is probably the most bittersweet feeling of this decade, the pain of outgrowing your old life. Sweet because you're evolving you're stepping into probably a more mature, concrete, self-aware version of you, bitter because part of growing up is having to say goodbye over and over again to certain things that
无论哪种情况，快去查看简介中的链接，你就能观看完整的Netflix节目。我们切入正题吧。本期节目将从一段“听我直言”（Hear Me Out）开始。听我说。身处二十岁最好的部分，是意识到你已经不再是曾经的那个自己；最糟糕的部分，则是再次意识到，无论你多么努力，或者多么想回到过去，你都再也回不去了。这或许是这个十年中最苦乐参半的感觉——超越旧生活的痛苦。之所以甜，是因为你在进化，你正在迈向一个或许更成熟、更立体、更有自我觉察的自己；之所以苦，是因为成长的一部分就是不得不一次又一次地向某些事物告别，
represented who you once were and just kind of hoping that the next chapter is better. This happens, this feeling this phenomenon occurs at some very critical points in our 20s. Like when we graduate college or university, I remember graduating and there being this like deep, sadness that, you know, I'm never going to live next door to my friends ever again. I'm never going to have those same moments and nights where you're like getting to know people for the first time and like everything is shiny and new and not that serious and like your whole job is just to study. Like I'd never get to relive this exactly as it was. That's a big one for many people. It can also happen when we break up with somebody, you know, you're grieving this old version of
这些事物曾代表了曾经的你，而你只能寄希望于下一个篇章会更好。这种情况、这种感觉、这种现象在我们二十岁的一些关键节点上经常发生。比如当我们大学毕业时。我记得自己毕业时有一种深深的悲伤，你知道的，我再也不会和朋友们住在隔壁了，再也不会有那种第一次去认识别人、一切都光鲜亮丽、崭新且没那么严肃的时刻了，那时你唯一的任务就是学习。我觉得自己再也无法原汁原味地重温这一切了。这对许多人来说都是个大事件。当我们和某人分手时，这种感觉也会出现，你知道的，你在为那个旧版本的自己感到悲伤，
you, you're grieving the life you thought you'd have and it kind of disintegrates very quickly. Same with when we quit jobs, when we leave cities, when we lose friends, even loved ones. But the pain of outgrowing your old life also happens a lot more quietly as we kind of realize like, hey, wait a second, I'm not who I was six months ago or two years ago or five years ago. Is that a good thing or is that a bad thing? Today we are going to explore that feeling for a second, the pain about growing your old life, why it hurts psychologically, why the pain is perhaps a good thing in a strange way, and how to just lean into this constant evolution of the self that we're going to experience time and time again. And I guess not cling
你在为曾经以为会拥有的生活感到悲伤，而这种生活很快就瓦解了。当我们辞职、离开城市、失去朋友，甚至是失去挚爱时，也是如此。但超越旧生活的痛苦也会在更安静的时候频繁发生，当我们突然意识到：“等等，我怎么和六个月前、两年前或五年前的我完全不一样了？”这是件好事还是一件坏事？今天，我们要花一点时间来探讨这种感觉：超越旧生活的痛苦、为什么它在心理上会带来痛感、为什么这种痛苦在某种奇怪的意义上又是一件好事，以及如何顺应这种我们将一次又一次经历的、不断的自我进化，
on too, too tightly to the past and miss out what will hopefully be an absolutely incredible, amazing future for you. So yeah, there's so much to cover. There's a lot of psychology. There's a a lot of concepts in this as well. So as always, let's get into it. Let's start with this. What are some clear signs, or maybe actually less than clear now that I think about it, but signs nonetheless that the life you used to have and love and feel safe in is now one that you've outgrown. Firstly, there is the very obvious fact that you know you've outgrown your old life because there has been a notable change, transition, major life event that has rapidly shifted timelines for you. We mentioned a few at the beginning, but some other big ones that we experience in our 20s are
我猜，就是不要对过去抓得太紧，从而错过了那段对你来说绝对难以置信、充满惊喜的美好未来。所以，是的，有太多的内容需要涵盖了。其中也包含了很多心理学知识和概念。因此，像往常一样，我们直接切入正题。让我们从这里开始：有些什么明显的迹象——仔细想想，或许现在看来也没那么明显——在表明你曾经拥有、热爱并从中感到安全的生活，现在已经被你超越了呢？首先，一个非常明显的现实是，你知道自己已经超越了旧生活，因为发生了一个显著的改变、过渡或重大生活事件，它迅速为你重置了时间线。我们在开头提到了一些，但在二十岁时经历的其他一些重大事件还有，
like things like grief, losing your job, having a big, maybe quite scary health change, health scare, even positive things like a new job, starting a new relationship, getting married. There's a feeling that everything's changed and there's a recognition of like, okay, I've crossed over a certain threshold that now I cannot go back on. Even if I were to go back, it wouldn't be the same. This may sound strange, but this happened to me a few weeks ago when my childhood dog passed away. Like I said, for me, it was a very clear moment in time that marked like a before and after. You know, I had him in my life since I was 10 years old from primary school to high school, to university, then when I moved to Sydney, then when I had my first full-time job,
比如悲伤、失业、经历了重大且可能相当吓人的健康转变、健康恐慌，甚至是一些积极的事情，比如换了新工作、开始一段新恋情、结婚。你会有一种一切都变了的感觉，并且你会意识到：“好吧，我已经跨过了一条无法回头的门槛。即使我想回去，也已经回不去了。”这听起来可能有点奇怪，但几周前我的童年宠物狗去世时，我就经历了这种感觉。就像我刚才说的，对我来说，这是一个非常清晰的时间节点，它标志着“之前”和“之后”。你知道的，从我10岁起他就一直在我的生活中，从小学到高中，到大学，然后我搬到悉尼，再到我找到第一份全职工作，
when I quit that job, literally he lasted from when I was a child to when I moved to London. And his death was like this moment of realization of like my old life, my childhood is officially over. Like there's no going back. So that was a big moment for me. Shout out to Yo-Yo. This episode is dedicated to Yo-Yo, the best dog ever. And it definitely, yeah, again, inspired this feeling in me of like this huge recognition of like I am no longer that person and I can never be that person again. So that took a sad turn. But yes, sometimes there is kind of an intense timeline shift that brings perspective also signifies the end of something. More subtly though, sometimes it's less of like an intense rupture and more of a slow recognition. It's more subtle.
当我辞去那份工作时，他真的陪伴了我从一个孩子到搬去伦敦的全过程。他的离去就像是一个顿悟的时刻，让我意识到：我的旧生活、我的童年正式结束了。这就是回不去了。所以对我来说这是一个很大的时刻。向悠悠（Yo-Yo）致敬。这一期节目献给悠悠，史上最好的狗狗。这确实——是的，再次在我心中激发了这种巨大的认知，让我意识到我不再是那个人了，我也永远无法再成为那个人。所以话题转向了一个悲伤的方向。但是，是的，有时会有一种强烈的时间线转变，它带来了新的视角，同时也标志着某种事情的结束。不过更微妙的是，有时它不是那种剧烈的断裂，而是一种缓慢的认知。它更微妙一些，
It's small changes in your routines, in your relationships. You may suddenly realize like, oh, I don't really see the people that I used to. My nights look very different now. Like a lot of my hobbies have changed. Even how I dress has changed. My idea of fun is different. Basically, there has been some personal evolution in terms of your values or your lifestyle that has slowly filtered into your habits and patterns over time. This can create some tension. I think if your environment remains the same, but you, no longer fit in it when there's a disalignment between you and the people you're around or the life that you're in you may also start to feel out of place where you are now bit bored
体现在你的日常生活、人际关系中的微小变化。你可能会突然意识到：“哦，我不常常见以前那些人了。我的夜生活现在看起来完全不同了。很多爱好都变了。甚至我的穿着也变了。我对快乐的定义也不同了。”基本上，随着时间的推移，你的价值观或生活方式发生了一些个人进化，并慢慢渗入了你的习惯和模式中。这可能会带来一些紧张感。我认为，如果你的环境保持不变，而你却不再适合它——当你和身边的人或者你所处的生活之间出现错位时，你可能也会开始对现状感到格格不入，
bit stuck bit restless i don't know if there's a psychology term for this but right before your life is about to change remarkably you will experience what i call next in line jitters this is this weird waiting room sensation where part of you instinctively knows you're about out to experience like a deep psychological, soulful, emotional transformation, but it's just not your turn yet. I don't, like, it's a hard feeling to describe. The best way I can describe it is the hour before a long haul flight lands. And you like, you know you're about to land. You know what's coming, but like you have to last the longest period of your life where like you can't really get comfortable, you can't really do anything. And it just feels very, very strange.
觉得有点无聊、有点卡壳、有点坐立不安。我不知道这在心理学上有没有专门的术语，但在你的生活即将发生显著改变之前，你会经历我所说的“下一阶段焦虑”（next in line jitters）。这是一种奇怪的候诊室般的感觉，你的一部分本能地知道你即将经历一场深刻的、心理上的、灵魂深处的、情感上的蜕变，但现在还轮不到你。我不知道……这是一种很难描述的感觉。我能想到的最好比喻，就是长途航班降落前的那一个小时。你知道自己马上要着陆了，你知道接下来会发生什么，但你却必须熬过生命中最长的一段时间，在这个时间里你无法真正感到舒适，也无法真正做任何事情。这种感觉非常非常奇特。
That's what next in line June is really feels like. Maybe my metaphor doesn't make sense, but I think the closest psychological term for it is developmental disequilibrium. It's actually a child psychology term that comes from the Yale-Gessel Institute of Child Development. And I think it definitely can also apply to adults, and especially people in their 20s as well. Basically what this term or this theory says is, right as you're on the verge of like a major growth spurt,
这就是“下一阶段焦虑”的真实感受。也许我的比喻说不通，但我认为最接近的心理学术语是“发展性失衡”（developmental disequilibrium）。这其实是一个儿童心理学术语，源自耶鲁-格塞尔儿童发展研究所（Yale-Gessel Institute of Child Development）。我认为它绝对也可以适用于成年人，尤其是二十多岁的年轻人。基本上，这个术语或理论所表达的是：就在你处于重大生长爆发的边缘时，
your behavior starts to almost regress. So we experience what feels like a drawback in our behavior, in our lifestyle, in our attitudes before we are kind of shot forward. And that strange feeling of displacement is a good thing. It's a sign that change is coming. You're just not quite there yet. But it's also, as much as it is a good thing, it's often accompanied by a lot of grief as well as we spoke about. And I think this is the biggest sign that you're outgrowing your old life. You know, it's painful. even if it's beautiful. Often the greatest sign that you're going through this right now
你的行为几乎开始出现退化。所以在我们被向前推进之前，我们在行为、生活方式和态度上都会经历一种看似倒退的现象。而这种奇怪的错位感其实是一件好事。这是一个改变即将来临的信号。你只是还没完全走到那一步。但与此同时，尽管这是一件好事，正如我们之前所讨论的，它往往也伴随着许多悲伤。我认为这是你超越旧生活最大的标志。你知道的，这是痛苦的，即使它是美好的。通常，你正在经历这一切的最大迹象，
is that you just feel it, right? You feel a little bit off, you feel sad. Maybe you don't have the exact kind of box to place it in or a way to categorize it, but you definitely don't feel like yourself. We've spoken about this before a lot of times, but the human brain has a natural aversion to large-scale change. It likes novelty.
就是你能真切地感受到它，对吧？你觉得有点不对劲，觉得难过。也许你没有准确的词汇去定义它，也没有找到将其归类的方式，但你绝对觉得自己不再是自己了。我们以前多次探讨过这个问题，人类的大脑对大规模的改变有一种天生的抗拒心理。它喜欢新鲜感，
It likes a little bit of a challenge for sure, but that rapid uncertainty of outgrowing a life that you felt comfortable in creates so many unknowns all at once that our mind can't really piece together the story of who we are right now. In the words of Harvard researchers, if your brain has one major vice, it is control. And there is very little of it. There is very little control right now in this period of change. and that combined with the loss of what once was and just the fact you can't have it anymore does create a very real emotional and psychological pain that can be felt like real pain. I think the pain is best described by this quote,
它当然也喜欢一点挑战，但在一个让你感到舒适的生活中，超越它所带来的那种迅速的不确定性，会同时引发太多的未知数，以至于我们的大脑无法拼凑出“此时此刻的我们究竟是谁”这个故事。用哈佛研究人员的话来说，如果你的大脑有一个主要的软肋，那就是控制欲。而在此时的转变期，这种控制力少之又少。在这一变革时期，控制力微乎其微，再加上对过往事物的失去，以及再也无法拥有它们的事实，确实会产生一种非常真实的情感和心理痛楚，这种痛楚可以被感知为真正的疼痛。我想，这种痛苦可以用这样一句话来最好地诠释：
the process of transformation consists mostly of decay. This is from Rebecca Solnit's book, A Field Guide to Getting Lost, and what she's basically describing is a phenomenon known in psychology and sociology as liminality. the threshold between who you were and who you are becoming that requires almost a full death of the old self before the new self can emerge. The very, very famous psychoanalyst, Carl Jung, who we speak about in basically every single episode, he of course had things to say about this and he spoke about it as the death and rebirth archetype where we basically have to constantly experience small deaths within us to bring
“转化的过程主要由腐烂组成。”这是丽贝卡·索尔尼特（Rebecca Solnit）的书《迷失指南》（A Field Guide to Getting Lost）中的话，她基本上是在描述心理学和社会学中被称为“边缘状态”（liminality）的现象。那是你是谁与你正在成为谁之间的门槛，在新的自我出现之前，几乎需要旧自我的彻底消亡。大名鼎鼎的精神分析学家卡尔·尤ング（Carl Jung）——我们在几乎每一集节目里都会提到他——对此当然也有所论述，他将其称为“死亡与重生原型”（death and rebirth archetype），即我们基本上必须在体内不断经历微小的死亡，才能带来
about newness and growth. Without those deaths, we cannot have that. And he claimed that this process was incredibly important for an individuation. Individuation is essentially the lifelong, psychological journey of discovering your authentic identity. This is what the pain is. This pain that you're experiencing right now. It is the decay that is required for the new growth. Now, something especially interesting to know, particularly if you're going through this right now and you're just kind of like floating flotsam like you really don't have an anchor. Something interesting to know is that the pain about growing your old life often occurs in stages and it does have an end point. The biggest theory on this is Arnold Van Genep's
新生与成长。没有这些死亡，我们就无法获得新生。他声称，这个过程对于“个性化”（individuation）来说极其重要。“个性化”本质上是发现你真实身份的终生心理之旅。这就是痛苦之所在。你现在正在经历的这种痛苦，正是新成长所必需的腐烂。现在，有一个特别有趣的事情需要了解，特别是如果你现在正经历这一切，感觉自己就像漂浮的残骸一样——真的没有锚点。有趣的是，超越旧生活的痛苦往往是按阶段发生的，而且它确实有一个终点。关于这一点最大的理论是阿诺德·范·根纳普（Arnold Van Genep）的
threefold model of the rites of passage. But I like to think of it as having seven stages in particular. We're going to start with his theory. He's the expert. Basically, Van Genep, He was a French ethnographer and folklorist. So he liked to understand humanity by looking at stories and the way that cultures functioned. And throughout his work, he kind of noticed that in almost all societies and cultures, as people transitioned into new seasons of life or new roles, the same three things almost always happened. There was separation, there was transition or the liminal space we speak about,
“过渡仪式三阶段模型”（threefold model of the rites of passage）。但我更愿意认为它具体分为七个阶段。我们先从他的理论讲起，他是这个领域的专家。基本上，范·根纳普是一位法国人类学家和民俗学家。因此，他喜欢通过观察故事和文化运作的方式来理解人类。在整个研究过程中，他注意到在几乎所有的社会和文化中，当人们过渡到新的生活阶段或新的角色时，几乎总会发生三件事：分离、过渡（或我们所说的边缘空间），
and then there was incorporation. The example that suits this best is, like, graduation, for example. There's the separation that is seen through, you know, the formality of the graduation ceremony. You receive a diploma, probably also a big fat bill. Even, like, the separation is signified even by the turning of the tassels on the hats, like showing that you've separated, you've exited this institution. Then there is the period of transition, maybe before you start work or before you know, what's going to come next where you've lost all the structure that you relied upon in the past
以及融入。最能说明这一点的例子，比如毕业典礼。首先是“分离”，这体现在毕业典礼的仪式感上。你收到了毕业证，可能还有一大笔账单。甚至连分离的标志也体现在将帽子上的流苏拨动方向上，这表明你已经分离了，你已经走出了这个机构。然后是“过渡”期，可能是在你开始工作之前，或者在你弄清楚接下来会发生什么之前，在这个时期，你失去了过去赖以生存且已经习惯的所有结构，而你在未来又没有什么可以真正依靠的。你留下了许多困惑、想法、关于“这能行得通吗？”或是“我要怎么办？”的疑问。然后他说，接下来是缓慢的“重新融入”。你把事情一点点拼凑起来。你重新融入。你对你现在所处的位置有了一种感觉。他还谈到，
and that you've become accustomed to and you don't really have anything else to rely on in the future. You're kind of left with a lot of confusion, thoughts, questions about is this going to work out or not? What am I going to do? And then he says there's slowly this reintegration. You kind of piece things together. You reintegrate. You get a sense of like where you are now. He also spoke about marriage being like this as well or a wedding being.
结婚或婚礼也是如此，参军也是如此。记住，他写作的时代大约是在20世纪初左右。因此，当时文化中的一个巨大组成部分——他经历过一些非常重大的战争——所以参军对他来说可能是最显而易见的例子。这就是他关于过渡仪式的理论：分离、过渡、重新融入。正如我所说，我认为这其实经历了更多的阶段。我觉得它可能没有三个步骤那么具体和简单。我认为超越旧生活的痛苦分成了七个阶段。第一阶段，也是你进入这一转变期的第一个标志，即第一阶段：怀旧情绪增加。你开始意识到自己非常怀念
like this, joining the military being like this. Remember, he was kind of like riding around the time of like the early 1900s. So a huge part of culture at that time, like he lived through some very significant wars. So people going to the army was probably the most obvious example for him. So that was his theory of the rights of passage, separation, transition, reintegration. As I've said, I see this as occurring in a few more stages. I think it's probably a little bit less concrete and simple than three steps. I think the pain of outgrowing your old life happens in seven. The first stage and the first sign that you are entering into this period of transformation is stage one, which is increased nostalgia. So you begin to realize you're really missing what
过去感觉很正常的事物。你开始按记忆中的样子去回忆事情，而不是它们现在的样子。随之而来的是对时间流逝的认可，以及一种更深的理解：“天哪，如果我感到怀旧，就意味着我不再拥有这一切了。事情已经变了。”这是一种苦乐参半的感觉。不过，紧随其后的是第二阶段：悲伤。我发现怀旧是一种你可以随时抽离、随时浸入的情绪。
used to feel normal. You're beginning to remember things kind of as they were, not as they are. and with that becomes the acknowledgement of the passing of time and just kind of the deeper understanding that like, oh my gosh, if I'm feeling nostalgic, it means that I don't have this anymore. Things have changed. That's a bit of sweet feeling. This is followed though by stage two, which is the grief. Nostalgia is something you can kind of dip in and out of I've found.
关于这一点有太多的研究，其中包括一项2023年的研究，题名为《在情绪中定位怀旧：从失落到爱的桥梁》（Locating Nostalgia Among the Emotions, A Bridge from Lost to Love）。在文中，作者探讨了怀旧如何成为那些既非积极也非消极的罕见情绪之一。它存在于它自己的空间里。然而，悲伤——至少在其早期阶段——就像是一堵巨大的悲伤与失落之砖墙。这就是事情变得真实的时候。怀旧就像是：哦，我觉得难过，但又有点高兴。而悲伤阶段就像是：哦，我真的在接受这样一个事实，即生活永远不会和从前一样了。这可能还伴随着一些恐慌，
There's so many studies on this, including one from 2023 titled, Locating Nostalgia Among the Emotions, A Bridge from Lost to Love. And in it, the author talks about how, nostalgia is one of those rare emotions that's neither positive or negative. It kind of exists in its own space. Grief, though, at least in its early stages, it's just like a big brick wall of sadness and loss. This is like when shit kind of gets real. Like nostalgia was like, oh, I feel sad, but I'm kind of happy. The grief stage is like, oh, I'm really coming to terms with the fact that life is never going to be the same. It's probably also some panic.
这也是其中一部分。于是我们进入了第三阶段，即真空阶段，也就是我们之前讨论过的边缘空间（liminal space）。在这个阶段，我们感觉自己糟糕透顶。老实说，这很可能就是你现在的状态。没有什么可以紧抓不放的。这种感觉，我能想到的最好的描述是：你只失去了东西，却几乎没有得到什么。直到目前为止你一直在失去。你不再拥有过去拥有的东西，但你还不知道未来有什么。你只是觉得对自己的现状失去了掌控。你的生活可能感觉不再属于你了。在这个状态里待多久，可以说是价值百万美元的问题。它的答案非常模棱两可，那就是它完全取决于你
that as well. And that is when we enter stage three, which is the vacuum stage, also the liminal space that we spoke about before. This stage is where we feel our just absolute worst. And it is likely where you are right now, if I'm being honest. There is very little to hold on to. It feels like, I think the best way to describe it is that you've only lost and you've gained very little. You're just losing up into this point. You don't have what you had in the past. You also don't know what is in the future yet. You just have the sense that you lack possession over your current state. Your life maybe doesn't feel like it's yours anymore. How long you stay in this state is like the million dollar question. It has a very ambiguous answer, which is that it really depends on how
能否很好地适应下一个阶段，也就是责任阶段或接受阶段。在这个时期，你真正开始接受现实的种种事实。比如在某个阶段，你必须去接受：不，我再也回不去那个人了；不，我无法回到过去了；不，过去是无法改变的。是的，这很让人难过。是的，为之悲伤是正常的。那么，我该对此做些什么呢？我要改变什么？因为你不可能永远停留在那个边缘空间里。相信我，我想确实有些人会那样做，而那些人往往是对生活最不满意的人，因为他们太执着于过去，完全无法看到自己对未来的作用和自主权。
well you can adjust to the next stage, which is the responsibility stage or the acceptance stage. in this period, you really begin to come to terms with the facts of the situation. Like at some stage, you have to just, you have to just accept like, no, I can never be that person again. No, I cannot go back there. No, there's no change in the past. Yes, that is sad. Yes, it is okay to grieve that. Now, what am I going to do about it? What am I going to change? Because you can't stay in that liminal space forever. Trust me, I think there are some people who do, and those are the people who seem least happy with their lives because they're just so fixated on the past and they're just so unable to see their own role and their agency over the future.
这方面的一些例子，就像你家乡那个总想重温高中时代的大叔，或者那个对痛苦的离婚耿耿于怀的人。并不是他们想变成那样，只是前两个阶段的悲伤和怀旧情绪太强烈了，以至于他们无法进入第三阶段——责任/接受阶段。这是一个令人感到不舒服的现实。在某个时刻，要么你选择放手，要么你被现实拖着走。这两者之间的转变，在于意识到你拥有自我效能感、拥有自主权，能够让接下来发生的事情和以前一样美好。那么，在这之后会发生什么？最后三个
Some examples of this are like the dude from your hometown who just wants to relive high school, the person who like can't get over their bitter divorce. It's not like they want to be that way. It's just that the grief and the nostalgia of the first two stages are too strong, that they're unable to get to stage three, which is the responsibility. acceptance stage. It's an uncomfortable reality. At some point, you either let go or you get dragged behind. The shift between one or the other is realizing that you have self-efficacy, you have agency, in making what comes next as good as it was before. So what happens after this? What are the three
阶段是什么，你可能在想？我们这里需要稍作休息，但回来后，我们将讨论所有这些以及更多内容。请继续关注我们。体验。你最终会怎么获得蒙特拉索音乐节（Lasso Montreal）的周末黄金门票。托马斯·雷特（Thomas Rett）。蒙福之子乐队（Mumford and Suss）。
final stages you may be thinking? We have to take a short break here, but when we come back, we're going to talk about all of that and so much more. Stay with us. Experience. You end up how with weekend gold tickets to Lassau Montreal. Thomas Rett. Mumford and Suss.
好吧，这是我的骄傲，这也是我的羞耻。约翰·帕迪（John Party）、老多明尼水手乐队（Old Dominion）、卡莉·皮尔斯（Carly Pierce）等等。奖品甚至更加丰厚。包括波特航空（Porter Airlines）的航班，蒙特利尔市中心Residence Inn酒店三晚住宿，
Well, here's my pride and here's my shame. John Party, Old Dominion, Carly Pierce, and more. And the prize gets even sweeter. With flights from Porter Airlines, three nights at Residence Inn downtown Montreal,
以及1000美元现金。下载免费的Iheart radio应用程序，收听Pure Country电台10分钟，即可参与赢取大奖。蒙特拉索音乐节。所有，你收听的每一天都是又一次获胜的机会。一旦你接受了现实，并承担起塑造现实的责任——我们在心理学上称之为接受你自己的自我效能感，这时你才真正
and $1,000 cash. Download the free Iheart radio app, listen to Pure Country for 10 minutes, and enter to win. Lasso, Montreal. All, every day you listen is another chance to win. Once you've accepted your reality and you've accepted your responsibility and shaping your reality, what we call in psychology accepting your own self-efficacy, this is when you start to really
开始能够塑造你的新处境。基本上，这就是你开始寻找新机会、新日常、新朋友的时候，你开始为自己设定新目标，并为此感到高兴。你真正开始拥有愿景、一丝乐观，并制定计划。然后，有一段时间什么都不会发生。第5阶段是我们所说的“成长的阵痛阶段”（discomfort of growth stage），在这个阶段，你正在真正做出牺牲。你知道有些东西必须离去。
begin to be able to shape your new situation. So basically, this is when you can start seeking out new opportunities, new routines, new friends, you start setting new goals for yourself, you're happy about it. You really start to have a vision, a bit of optimism, you make a plan. And then nothing really happens for a while. Stage 5 is what we call the discomfort of growth stage, where you're truly making sacrifices now. You know things need to go.
你知道自己需要一个全新的开始。你知道必须做些什么才能迎来你想要未来。这需要时间。这只是——很难经历。在经历了你已经经历过的一切以及你可能已经感受到的痛苦之后，这听起来可能有点扫兴。但不要害怕。这个阶段会过去的。
You know you need a clean slate. You know what needs to be done to bring about the future that you want. And it takes a while. It's just, it's hard. Sounds like a bummer after what you've already been through and what you probably already feel. But do not fear. It does pass.
紧随其后的慢慢是第六阶段，即回报的回归。一开始很慢，但你开始注意到事情在发生变化。比如你感觉更轻松了，不再那么悲观了。你找到了适合自己的节奏。缓慢回报阶段是最棒的，因为你挺过来了，并且你证明了：“我确实有能力进化。”生活可能没有变得更好或更坏，但它不同了。
And it is followed slowly by stage 6, which is the return of reward. Slow at first, but you begin to start to notice things shifting. Like you're feeling lighter, you're not as pessimistic. You found a bit more of a groove. The slow reward stage is the best because you kind of made it through and you've proven, like, I'm really capable of evolving. And life may not be better or worse, but it's different.
而这种不同本身就是一种回报。而且有些事情是我真正喜欢这个新版本的自己的地方，也是我所期待的。你当然还是会感到阵阵怀旧的刺痛，但我认为这种渴望只是你还是个人类、并且你已经将过去的经历深深内化的证明。现在你也在为现在做同样的事。你开始真正享受你现在拥有的一切。
And that difference is its own reward. And there are things that I genuinely enjoy about this new version of me and that I'm looking forward to. Definitely you still feel pangs of nostalgia, but I think yearning is just to sign you're human and that you've deeply embodied your past experiences. Now you are just doing that for the present as well. You're starting to really enjoy what you have now.
这就是我们到达最后阶段——第七阶段，即新常态（new normal）。用弗利特伍德·麦克乐队（Fleetwood Mac）的话来说，你已经爬上了山峰，并转过身来。我知道这听起来很老套，但这是描述它的最好方式。一开始这种感觉很微妙。我搬到伦敦和海外生活时就有这种体会，对吧？比如一开始，我真的很讨厌它，讨厌它，讨厌它，然后慢慢地，我想得少了，我投入了更多的精力让它感觉正常，让它感觉这一切都是值得的。然后就像分手一样，你知道的，有一天你一觉醒来，你觉得一切都好，就是那种感觉。有一天，
This is when we arrive at the final stage, stage seven, which is the new normal. In the words of Fleetwood Mac, you've climbed the mountain, you've turned around. I know it sounds cheesy, but it's just the best way to describe it. it's subtle at first. I found this with moving to London and moving overseas, right? Like at first, I really hated it and I hated it and I hated it and then slowly I thought about it less and I put in more effort to make it feel normal and to make it feel worth it. And then kind of like a breakup, like, you know, one day you just wake up and you feel okay, that's what it was like. One day,
它感觉就像是新常态了。然后你突然意识到：我只是喜欢我现在所在的地方。我很幸福。正如卡尔·尤ング所说——我们当然不得不再次提到他——他说这个循环将在你的一生中一次又一次地发生。然而，最能应对好这一点的人，正是那些顺应其流动的人。没有什么东西会永远保持不变，但无论如何，你可能也不希望它保持不变。我认为这种痛苦，如果说别的没有，至少它证明了：“嘿，我有值得怀念的东西。”我曾拥有过值得怀念的东西。它确凿地表明，你曾拥有过你所热爱的生活，或是其中你所热爱的部分。
it just felt like the new normal. And you just kind of realize I just like where I am now. I'm happy. as Carl Jung said, we have to bring him up again, of course. He said this cycle is going to occur over and over again throughout your life. The people who handle this the best, though, are those who just submit to the flow of it. Nothing stays the same forever, but you probably wouldn't want it to anyway. I think this pain, as well, if nothing else, is just proof that, hey, like, I have something worth missing. I had something worth missing. It shows you conclusively that you have had a life that you've loved or parts of it that you've loved.
你曾拥有过你所爱的人。因此，外面也存在着另一种你可以去热爱的生活版本。这本身就是生活很有价值的证明。我认为同样重要的是，不要把焦点放在放手和继续前进时你所失去的东西上，而是要去想想，如果你对一个不再适合你的生活抓得太紧，你会失去什么。你知道，在这种情况下你会失去什么？首先，你会失去接触未来那个可能更真实的自己的机会。你会失去接触那些正等待着你去开启的新机会的机会。
You've had people that you've loved. And therefore there is another version of a life you can love out there as well. Like it's proof in itself that life is valuable. I think it's also important to not focus on what you've lost by letting go and moving on, but what you would have lost by holding on too tight to a life that didn't fit you anymore. You know, what do you lose in that situation? Firstly, you lose access to a future version of you who is probably more authentic. You lose access to new opportunities that are just waiting for you to be available for them.
人际关系也是如此。如果你腾出空间和时间给他们，你就会失去接触那些你所爱的朋友和人们的机会。如果你停滞不前，你就会失去接触新课程和新体验的机会。你几乎肯定会失去能力，或者失去生活给你带来惊喜的能力。我想，你还会失去体验一种比以往任何时候都更真实、甚至更纯粹的幸福的可能性。这可能很难想象，考虑到你有多喜欢你目前拥有的东西，这很可能确实如此，但我们经常犯下一个认知错误，认为我们所经历的一切一定就是我们未来所能体验到的一切的上限。基本上，这就是最好的情况了。就像，生活也就这样了，
Same thing with relationships. You lose access to friends and people you love if you made space and time for them. You lose access to new lessons and new experiences if you stayed the same. You would almost certainly lose the ability or lose life's ability to surprise you. And I think you also just lose access to the possibility for a genuine, perhaps even pure happiness than you've ever experienced. This may be hard to imagine, and it probably is given how much you like what you have, but we often make the cognitive error of believing that all we've ever experienced must be the ceiling for all that we will ever experience. Basically, it's as good as it ever was. Like, this is as good as it gets.
我们变得如此执着于我们所失去的，以至于忘记去考虑抓得太紧的机会成本。我们可以清楚地看到我们正在抛弃的生活。我们可以清楚地看到我们喜欢它的哪些方面。我们无法看到在另一端等待着我们的生活，因为它还没有发生。心理学家甚至经济学家有一些术语，试图解释这会对我们的行为产生什么影响。其中一个术语是“禀赋效应”（endowment effect）。它也可能被称为“现状偏见”（status quo bias）。基本上，我们珍视我们已经拥有的东西，因为我们对它很熟悉。这意味着我们不会去考虑可能更好的替代方案。我们很难去评估那些替代方案——你知道的，那个向你走来的未来——因为相比于已经成为过去的事情，它感觉不够真实。
and we become very fixated on what we're losing, that we forget to consider the opportunity cost of holding on too tight. We can clearly see the life we're leaving behind. We can clearly see what we liked about it. We can't see the life waiting for us on the other side because it hasn't happened yet. Psychologists and even economists have a few terms they use to try and explain what this does to our behavior. One term they use is the endowment effect. It may also be known as the status quo bias. Basically, we value what we already have because we're familiar with it. And that means that we don't consider alternatives that may be better. We struggle to value those alternatives, you know, the future that's coming for you because it doesn't feel as real
然而，紧抓不放是有代价的。即使此刻你觉得因为自己保持不变而失去得更少，但你真正失去的，是自我拓展的机会。我认为关于这种限制在心理和发展上对我们造成的影响，最好的比喻就是金鱼缸隐喻（fishbow metaphor）。我确信我们都听说过这样一个观点：金鱼会长得和鱼缸一样大。我认为同样地，人们也只能成长到他们所能承受的不适感的大小。那正是他们的极限所在。
as what already was. Holding on, though, costs you something. Even if in the moment you feel like you're losing less because you're staying the same, what you're really losing, is that opportunity for self-expansion. I think the best metaphor for what this limitation does to us psychologically and developmentally is the fishbow metaphor. I'm sure we've all heard this idea that a goldfish will grow to the size of its tank. I think equally people can only grow to the size of their discomfort. That's where their limit is.
如果你不允许自己坐在那个空间里，去体验那种痛苦，如果你只是、并且总是回到你曾经拥有的东西并试图去重温它，你就是在把自己关在一个小鱼缸里。你在自我设限。2022年，研究人员伍利（Woolie）和费什巴赫（Fishbarsh）进行了一项出色的研究，并发表在《心理科学杂志》（Journal of Psychological Sciences）上。他们测验了“积极寻求不适感作为成长信号”是否能提高动机。
if you don't allow yourself to sit in that space, experience that pain, and if you only, and you always just go back to what you had and try and relive it, you are putting yourself in a small fishbowl. You are containing yourself. There was an amazing study done in 2022 by researchers, Woolie and Fishbarsh, and it was published in the Journal of Psychological Sciences, where they measured whether actively seeking discomfort as a signal for growth could increase motivation.
他们总共做了大约五项实验，涉及大约2000名甚至更多的成年人。他们的发现是：当人们奔向不适感，因为他们在心理上将其视为成长的信号和自我提升的途径时，他们目标的达成度要高得多。当他们接受不适感并认为这可能是一件好事，并且自愿希望在生活中体验更多时，他们的表现就会更好。这正是我真正希望你们能够做到的，如果坦白说的话，这也是我希望自己能够做到的：拥有这样一种能力——改变我们对不适感的理解，把超越人群、地方、特定时间点的痛苦，视为一种本质上是礼物的存在。它是变革性的。它不是惩罚。它不是悲伤。它字面意义上就是生活的全部意义所在——
They did like five experiments with like 2,000, I think even more adults in total. And what they found was that when people run towards discomfort because they mentally see it as a sign of growth and a way to improve themselves, their level of goal achievement was much, much higher. when they accept discomfort as perhaps being a good thing and they voluntarily want more of it in their life, they do better. And this is what I really want for you guys. And if I'm being honest, what I want for myself, the ability to shift our understanding of discomfort and the pain of outgrowing people, places, moments in time to be something that is actually at its core a gift. It's transformational. It's not punishment. It's not sadness. It is literally the whole point of life
那就是不断成长。带着这个想法，在我们结束本期节目之际，让我们来谈谈保持对自身进化的积极心态、同时又尊重过去的自己和过去的三个简单具体的方法。首先，当你超越了旧生活时，一定要具体注意有什么不同，以及为什么这种差异很重要。这让我想起前几天看到的一句话，我不记得是谁说的了，但它大意是：每一个篇章之所以痛苦，是因为它与众不同，但它之所以重要，恰恰正是因为这些差异。基本上，你生活中的每一个阶段都有其独特而特别的东西可供提供，这是你生命的任何其他部分都无法比拟的。无论你是19岁、35岁、70岁还是90岁，总会有一些你第一次经历的体验，
is to keep growing. So with that in mind, as we kind of wrap up the episode, let's talk about three easy concrete ways to keep positive about our evolution whilst also honoring who we were before and our past. Firstly, as you outgrow your old life, make sure you notice specifically what is different and why that difference is important. It reminds me of a quote I saw the other day, I can't remember who said it, but it essentially said each chapter is painful because it is different, but it is important specifically because of those differences. Basically, each period of your life has something uniquely special to offer that no other part of your life can. Whether you are 19, 35, 70, 90, there is always going to be an experience you are having for the first time
它在考验你、拓展你。对于你目前所处的阶段，那种体验是什么？我认为更具体地切入这一点的方法是写下来：你认为生活此刻正试图教会你什么教训？生活正在让你经历什么样的特定研讨会、课程或模块，你希望在另一端看到什么样的学习成果，或者你认为生活正在向你传授什么？这真的、真的很有效，回归到一个教训并试图识别出模式是什么，这一点非常重要，因为它从我们的失落中创造了意义。有一种观点认为，当失落看似毫无理由或目的时，它带来的痛苦最深、也最深刻。因此，通过重新赋予意义——“这是我从中学到的教训”，我们为自己的痛苦和悲伤创造了一个叙事，这使得它们更容易被整合、更容易被忍受。所以这是一种方法。其次，当你感觉到自己正在过渡并把旧生活抛在身后时，特别是，当你感觉到想要抓得太紧的冲动和渴望时，问问自己：你是在为谁做这件事？这种不适感将为谁服务？事实是，为了你自己，为了你未来的自己。你为了更好或更坏的未来，心甘情愿地让自己经受这种改变，因为你知道，未来自己的回报将会是极其丰厚的。新机会、新成长、
ever that is testing you and expanding you. For the period you are in right now, what is that experience? I think an even more concrete way to tap into this is to write down what lesson do you think life is trying to teach you right now? What specific seminar, course, module is life putting you through and one is the learning outcome that you are hoping to see at the other end or that you think is being delivered to you? This is really really. effective, this, you know, coming back to a lesson trying to identify what the pattern is is really important because it creates meaning from our loss. There is this idea that loss hurts the most and is the most profound when it seemingly has no reason or purpose. So by adding
新关系、新体验的回报。你现在可能还感觉不到，但你知道它会是美好的。你越是能想象你的未来，甚至是那些最微小的细节以及你未来的自己将会享受的生活，你越是能描绘出这一切的另一面以及这种改变的果实，它就会越少地感觉像一种惩罚、越少地感觉像一种悲伤，而更像是一种——我不知道合适的词是什么——也许是一种奉献，也许是一种美妙的牺牲，甚至如果能达到那个点的话，会让人觉得令人兴奋。我前几天实际上在Instagram上谈到了这一点，我们在几乎所有做的事情中，获得成功的最大预测指标之一，就是我们进行所谓“逆向延迟折扣”（reverse delay discounting，也被称为延迟满足）的能力，也就是珍视
meaning back in, you know, this is the lesson I'm taking from this, we create a narrative to our pain and to our grief and that makes it easier to integrate and easier to tolerate. So that's one way to do it. Secondly, as you feel yourself transitioning and leaving your old life behind, and specifically, I think, as you feel the urge and the desire to just like hold on, perhaps too tightly, remember who you are doing this for? Who is this discomfort going to serve? The thing is, it's you, it's your future self. You are willingly subjecting yourself to this change for better or for worse because you know that the rule, that the rule, reward for future you is going to be spectacular. The reward of new opportunities, new growth,
那些稍后到来的回报、胜过珍视眼前的回报的能力。这对于选择超越旧生活至关重要，因为正如我们所说，将会有一个精神和情感的低谷期，在这个时期里，你就像是在白白送出你生命中的碎片。但随后总会有别的东西进来填补这个空缺。总是如此。我知道这听起来很荒谬。也许非常玄学。
new relationships, new experiences. You may not be able to feel it right now, but you know it's going to be good. The more you can visualize your future, even like the tiniest details and the life that your future self will be enjoying, the more you can picture the other side of this and the fruits of this change, the more it will feel less like a punishment, less like a sadness, and more like, I don't know the right word, maybe a devotion, maybe a beautiful sacrifice, maybe even exciting if you can get to that point. I spoke about this actually on Instagram the other day, but one of the single greatest predictors of success in almost everything we do is our ability for what we call reverse delay discounting, also called delay gratification, the ability to value
但我已经在很多人的生活中看到它发生了。比我年长的人，比我年轻的人，和我同龄的人，他们腾出了空间。他们牺牲了生活的一部分。更好的东西就会进来。并且把它填满。他们离开了一段明知不该呆在里面的关系。突然之间，为他们一直向往的灵魂伴侣级别的友谊敞开了空间。他们决定辞去讨厌的工作，重新回到学校。会有一段艰难的时期，然后就会有空间去做一些真正能赋予他们意义的事情。我想，重要的事情是：去想象未来，就像你想象过去一样多。就像你执着于失去的东西一样，同样地去执着于你将要获得的东西。最后，在你感到悲伤的地方，为感激留下同样广阔的空间。有时当我谈到感激时，我觉得我需要做一个这样的说明：感激并不是为了淹没所有其他的情绪。它只是为了和它们并存。比如，我很难过，我再也不可能是21岁了。但我非常感激我曾拥有过那些时光。我很焦虑，我再也不会像以前那样快乐了——在那份工作中，和那个人在一起，在那个地方。但我非常感激我深知那种快乐是真实存在的，而许多人却并不知道这一点。
rewards that come later more than rewards that come right now. This is essential for choosing to grow out of your old life because, as we said, there is going to be a mental and emotional trench period where it's like you are just giving pieces of your life away for free. But then something always comes in to fill its place. Always. I know that sounds ridiculous. Maybe very woo-woo.
如果你能做到这一点，你就实现了人类情商的最伟大指标之一，那就是能够同时容纳两个平行的、甚至是相互矛盾的真理与情绪，而不需要抹杀它们。这其实就是生活。这字面意思就是生活本身。容纳好的，容纳坏的，看见它们，并看到它们可以共存，它们不需要分出胜负，生活也不需要非此即彼。
But I have seen it happen in so many people's lives. People older than me, people younger than me, people my age, they leave space. They sacrifice parts of their life. Something better comes in. and fills it up. They leave a relationship they knew they shouldn't be in. And suddenly there is this space open for those soulmate level friendships they always wanted. They decide to quit the job, they hated and go back to school. There's a hard period and then there's space to do something that actually gives them meaning. I guess the important thing is to imagine the future as much
但我见过许多人的生活都发生过这种情况。比我年长的人、比我年轻的人、与我同龄的人，他们都在腾出空间。他们牺牲了生活的一部分。更好的东西进来了，并将其填满。他们结束了一段明知不该维持的关系。突然间，他们一直渴望的灵魂伴侣般的友谊有了空间。他们决定辞去厌恶的工作，重返校园。经历了一段艰难的时期，然后就有空间去做一些真正赋予他们意义的事情。我想最重要的是，我们要尽可能地去想象未来
as you are imagining the past. As much as you are fixating on what you have lost, fixate equally on what you have to gain. And finally, where you feel sadness, leave equal space for gratitude. Sometimes when I talk about gratitude, I feel like I need to make this caveat. Gratitude isn't meant to drown out all the other emotions. It's just meant to sit alongside them. Like, I'm sad. I'm never going to be 21 again. But I'm so grateful I had those times. I'm anxious that I'm never going to be as happy as I was. in that job, with that person, in that place. But I'm so grateful I know that a happiness of that kind exists when so many people don't.
就像你想象过去一样。就像你执着于失去的东西一样，同样要执着于你将要获得的东西。最后，每当你感到悲伤时，也要为感恩留出同样的空间。有时当我谈到感恩时，我觉得我需要做一个这样的说明。感恩并不是为了淹没所有其他的情绪。它只是为了与它们并存。比如，我很伤心。我再也不可能回到21岁了。但我无比感激我曾拥有过那些时光。我感到焦虑，担心自己再也不会像以前那样快乐了，在那份工作中，和那个人在一起，在那个地方。但我无比感激的是，我知道这种程度的幸福是存在的，尽管许多人并不曾拥有。
If you can do this, you accomplish one of the greatest indicators of human emotional intelligence, which is the ability to hold two parallel, perhaps contradictory truths and emotions at one time and not need to cancel them out. That's kind of what life is. Like that's literally what life is. Holding the good, holding the bad, seeing them and seeing that they can exist, they can co-exist, they don't need to be, or life doesn't need to be one or the other.
如果你能做到这一点，你就实现了人类情商最高指标之一，那就是能够同时容纳两个平行的、也许是矛盾的事实和情感，而不需要互相抵消。这就是生活。字面意思就是生活。拥抱美好，拥抱糟糕，看到它们并看到它们可以存在，它们可以共存，它们不需要非此即彼，或者生活不需要非此即彼。
On top of that, we also know from countless neuro and psychological studies that gratitude has a physical impact on your brain. Just last year, the American Brain Foundation put out this massive report showing all the ways and all the research that gratitude shows up in brain imaging scan. in emotional regulation, in life satisfaction, those are all things we probably need when we are outgrowing the places that we've been. I also think this makes for a great journaling exercise. Even just a mental exercise, every time you miss something, every time you're confronted by the sadness of growing up, write down something you're equally excited for, something that you're
最重要的是，无数神经学和心理学研究表明，感恩对你的大脑有着实质性的影响。就在去年，美国大脑基金会发布了一份庞大的报告，展示了感恩在脑部扫描中显示的各种方式和研究。在情绪调节、生活满意度方面，当我们超越过去的自己时，这些可能都是我们需要的东西。我也觉得这是一个很好的写日记的练习。甚至只是一个心理练习，每当你怀念什么，每当你面对长大的悲伤时，写下一件你同样期待的事，一件让你
equally happy that you are going to get to experience. My final thing to say about the pain of outgrowing your old life is it can be very lonely. it can be very off-putting, but don't for a second think life can't get good again and perhaps even better than it was before. I have been so obsessed with these questionnaires and studies and even personal accounts I've been seeing at the moment where people ask those in their 80s and 90s, you know, when were you the happiest? The amount of them who say 50, 60, 70, and the amount of them who so rarely say 20 is so comforting to me. You think it's as good as it's going to get, it probably isn't.
同样感到高兴去体验的事。关于超越旧生活带来的痛苦，我要说的最后一点是，这可能会非常孤独，可能会让人感到扫兴，但千万不要有一秒钟认为生活不会再变好了，甚至可能比以前更好。我最近对这些问卷调查、研究甚至个人见闻着迷不已，人们会问那些八九十岁的人，你知道，你们什么时候最快乐？其中很多人说50岁、60岁、70岁，而很少有人说20岁，这让我感到非常欣慰。你以为生活就这么好了，其实大概并非如此。
I also just always remind myself when I feel like I didn't get enough time with a certain chapter in my life, would I have wanted to stay there forever? Probably not. Would I want that to be my only reality? No. And that means that sometimes I don't get the chance to decide or I don't get to choose when a new chapter begins. I just have to lean into it and just kind of have this blind hope that it is what's meant to be and that some part of you knows intuitively and instinctively that this life, this situation isn't working.
每当我觉得自己和生活中的某个阶段相处的时间不够时，我也会提醒自己，我愿意永远停留在那里吗？可能不会。我希望那是我的全部现实吗？不。这意味着有时我没有机会做决定，或者我无法选择新篇章何时开始。我只能顺其自然，并怀有一种盲目的希望，相信这就是命中注定，并且你内心的某个部分会凭直觉和本能知道，这种生活、这种境况已经行不通了。
Trust that gut instinct. Trust that discomfort that we've kind of been trained to ignore and have enough courage to be like, I actually want more for myself. even if that means going through a period of liminality, of emptiness, of pain, I really want what's on the other side. And so I'm willing to go through that. And I can. I can absolutely get through it. So that is our episode on the pain about growing your old life. I hope that it was helpful, especially if you are going through this right now. This has been like the entire last six months for me. and I do feel like I'm kind of at the new normal, on the new normal side of it all. And so it's kind of nice looking back and being like, wow, that was really worth it,
相信那种直觉。相信那种我们被训练去忽视的不适感，并拿出足够的勇气说：我其实想要为自己争取更多。即使这意味着要经历一段过渡期、空虚期和痛苦期，我也真的很想要彼岸的东西。所以我愿意经历这一切。而且我完全可以，我绝对能熬过去。这就是我们关于超越旧生活之痛的一期节目。我希望它能对你有所帮助，尤其是当你此刻正在经历这一切的时候。过去六个月对我来说基本上就是这样的，而且我觉得我已经来到了新常态的一边，适应了新常态。所以回过头来看，感觉真的很好，会觉得，哇，这一切真的很值得，
even though it really sucked in many, many ways. So I'm hoping that you get a similar revelation or a similar epiphany very, very soon. I'm absolutely certain you're going to make it through. If you have made it this far and you are listening on Spotify, leave a little comment down below, what stage of the seven stage process are you in right now? I'm hoping it's near the end, but if it's near the beginning, that's all right. You've got a ways to go, but it's going to change.
尽管它在很多很多方面确实很糟糕。所以我希望你很快也能有类似的启示或顿悟。我绝对相信你能挺过去。如果你听到了这里，并且正在Spotify上收听，请在下方留个小评论，你现在处于七个阶段中的哪一个阶段呢？我希望它快接近尾声了，但如果还在初期也没关系。你还有一段路要走，但这一切都会改变的。
It's going to get better for you. As always, as a reminder, you can watch episodes just like this one on Netflix if you want to go and check it out and support me and the podcast. It is a big thing for Netflix to do and to especially entrust us with the psychology of your 20s listeners. So, yeah, it would really mean the world if you would check out an episode. You can also get in touch and. get involved in so many other ways. We have a substack. We have an Instagram that you can
一切都会好起来的。一如既往，提醒大家，如果你想去看看并支持我和我的播客，你可以在Netflix上观看像这样的节目。Netflix能做这件事，特别是把《二三十岁心理学》的听众交给我们，这意义重大。所以，去看看某集节目对我来说真的意义非凡。你还可以通过许多其他方式与我们取得联系并参与进来。我们有Substack。我们还有一个Instagram，你可以
reach out to me through so many things, all in the description. But again, I hope you enjoyed this episode. Until next time, be safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself. We will talk very, very soon. This is an I-Heart podcast, guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
通过它联系我，途径有很多，都在简介里。但再次感谢，希望你喜欢这期节目。下次见，注意安全，保持善良，对自己温柔一些。我们很快就会再聊。这是一个iHeart播客，纯人工制作。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。